[Musique]
pourquoi pourquoi faire des milliers
d'heures de méditation jusqu'à en
devenir professeur certifié en yoga
kundalini mais pourquoi pourquoi dès
l'âge de 20 ans s'engager à suivre 17
ans de psychanalyse mais pourquoi
pourquoi aller voir des centaines depuis
l'âge de 11 ans des centaines de médium
et voyant en tout genre et pourquoi
faire des dizaines de constellations
familiales mais pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi
ok quand je me pose la question de mais
pourquoi dans mon coeur il y a un besoin
de famille
mais ça veut dire quoi une famille ça se
met à l'aise comment une famille pour
moi c'est ça se concrétise comment une
famille alors pour moi une famille c'est
dans l'amour un mari des enfants et une
maison de famille
aujourd'hui je suis la maman d'un petit
garçon qui n 9 mois et qui s'appelle
elon et ça me rend extrêmement heureuse
mon métier c'est de codiriger une grosse
start up dans l'environnement et
l'économie circulaire est d'être au
conseil d'administration de positif
planète alors quelque part peut-être
vous vous dites c'est une femme
indépendante ambitieuse pour qui tout
réussit plutôt pas mal
merci c'était risqué merci pour qui tout
est facile voir une femme de pouvoir
avec tous les préjugés qui vont avec
mais en fait non pas du tout
même si ma vie de famille et mon
engagement professionnel aujourd'hui
font que je suis vraiment heureuse il ya
quelques temps à très longtemps on
aurait pu se dire c'est impossible c'est
impossible que j'aie ma famille c'est
impossible
ça n'arrivera jamais ça ne m'arrivera
jamais parce que ma vie nan c'est pas un
conte de fées et l'honnête un petit
garçon très joyeux et très entourées
d'un amour absolu
elon jeu l'élève seule
elon j'ai eu avec un donneur anonyme
il y a quelques mois ma mère est morte
dans mes bras
alors que j'étais enceinte de six mois
mon père un alzheimer et surtout très
jeune j'étais trop confronté à la
douleur la solitude et la responsabilité
oui j'avais des parents gravement
dysfonctionnelle mais j'ai un avantage
oui c'est vrai j'en ai un c'est que ça
m'a obligé
enfin plus précisément ça m'a permis
d'aller chercher cette équation pour
réussir à atteindre mes désirs j'ai dû
aller le chercher mon bonheur
malgré mon histoire passée et malgré le
regard des autres sont mes choix de vie
l'équation du réussi
pour réussir ses désirs la première
chose c'est qu'il faut se libérer il
faut absolument se libérer des idéaux
qui sont pas les siens il faut se
libérer des idéaux qui sont ceux de
notre famille qui sont ceux de la
société qui sont soucieux de nos mondes
contemporains et surtout après il faut
clarifier ses désirs
qu'est ce qui m'anime qu'est ce qu'il me
met en joie qu est ce qui me fait
sourire qu est ce qui me fait aimer
qu'est ce qui me fait vibrer alors je
vous fais une confidence
moi aussi moi aussi comme toutes les
femmes de 40 ans que je connais j'avais
envie d'avoir un enfant avec quelqu'un
et dans l'amour
moi aussi mais voilà divorcée l'âge
faisant j'avais un seul choix pour avoir
cette famille c'était par donneur
anonyme
et croyez moi ça n'a pas été un choix
facile j'ai dû faire le deuil de mon
conte de fées j'ai dû faire le deuil de
mon schéma idéal
j'ai surtout dû faire le deuil de
l'approbation générale
heureusement sur mon chemin j'ai
rencontré énormément de bienveillance et
de soutien de personnes qui sont devenus
ma famille reconstituée
je suis d'origine turque est auvergnate
j'ai été élevé entre ci voyant et marc
de café
ceci dit ça m'a permis d'investiguer
depuis plus de 30 ans toute forme de
thérapie alors des thérapies classiques
jungienne gestalt yens freudienne les
thérapies alternatif vois franchement
ésotérique chamanisme étiologie
accrochez-vous étiologie psycho magie
psychogénéalogie akashi tricorne
constellations familiales et cetera et
cetera en soit on peut dire que je suis
devenue une experte en découverte de soi
en fait je suis devenue une experte ont
découvert deux mois en découverte de
comment mettre en oeuvre l'équation pour
réaliser mes désirs est-ce que ça m'a
permis cette quête d' essentiel
cette recherche en profondeur en fait
c'est de me sentir plus libre
c'est de me libérer de mes croyances
limitantes et surtout du mit béret des
vestiges de l'inconscient collectif et
de m'autoriser à construire ma vie de
famille dans un ordre et une temporalité
qui sont les miennes ça veut dire
embrasser la réalité exactement telle
qu'elle est maintenant et pour moi
c'était par donneur anonyme
tout en sachant qu'un homme arrivera ou
pas dans ma vie alors je vous raconte ça
ça a l'air évident comme ça en quelques
phrases et c'est mon jour passe le temps
et non d'aller que ça prend pour autant
la première chose à faire c'est que il
faut vraiment ça demande un courage
énorme et ça me demande encore du
courage aujourd'hui alors qu'elle en a
neuf mois et ça demande aussi
dès les guérir ses blessures parce que
ton qu'on a des blessures en nous on a
des murs de peur des murs de prétexte
qu'ils font que jamais on va aller pour
atteindre cdr on va toujours trouver des
tonnes de raisons pour ne pas aller les
chercher
alors que le plus important le plus
important c'est d'identifier ses désirs
et de se mettre en mouvement une fois
qu'on est à l'union de se mettre en
mouvement pour aller les mettre en
oeuvre et les réaliser parce que la
deuxième point important dans l'équation
du désir une fois qu'ils sont identifiés
et qu'on est aligné c'est de se mettre
en mouvement
alors j'ai pas attendu le combo parfait
mari enfants maison de famille pour
avancer et je me suis demandé mais où
est ce que je peux agir
il y a deux ans j'étais en vacances au
costa rica avec mon chéri de l'époque
vacances qui se passe très très mal
rupture il prend l'avion trois jours
avant la fin des vacances et là je me
dis wow je suis dans un chaos complet
ma vie de famille est au point zéro
qu'est ce que je vais faire
et donc là je souris mais je souriais
pas et est donc je me dis ok il faut que
je commence quelque part une femme
d'action
il faut que je commence quelque part et
en 48 heures au fin fond du costa rica
je suis allée acheter une maison mais
pas une maison une maison de famille
parce que pour moi une maison de famille
c'est un lieu pour accueillir pour
réunir sa famille pour se poser et pour
moi symboliquement et matériellement
c'était extrêmement important de sentir
que je démarre et cette équation pour
mettre en oeuvre et réaliser cette
famille je suis rentré en france et deux
mois après par donneur anonyme
j'étais enceinte
une fois aligné en mouvement enceinte
jusqu'à enceinte je suis dit faut que je
change de job il faut que j'ai un job
qui ait du sens et fred jeunes qu'ils
soient alignés à mes valeurs et donc
enceinte jusque là j'ai passé des
entretiens et j'ai fait des études
d'agronomie la nature et l'environnement
c'est fondamental pour moi le digital
c'est mon expertise et donc je suis allé
trouver un job exactement dans ce
secteur un job où je puisse contribuer
la planète et un job dans sois fier pour
mon fils est pour moi
l'enseignement que j'ai tirée de tout
cela c'est que une fois qu'on est aligné
et vous l'aurez compris c'est un sacré
job de s'aligner ça veut dire de
l'introspection
ça veut dire des moments de silence des
moments de pause mais une fois qu'on est
aligné et une fois qu'on se met en
mouvement quand les opportunités de se
présente cette fois ci on est prêt à les
saisir comme une maison
alors cette équation pour réaliser ses
désirs c'est pas du tout linéaire ni
dans l'ordre dit dans le temps on teste
on tombe on se ramasse on se relève et
on recommence
j'ai lancé trois start-up avant de
réussir il faut faire corps avec le
chaos que le chaos devienne notre allié
qui deviennent notre notre ami parce que
le plus important c'est de se ramener
toujours à l'essentiel est de se mettre
en mouvement pour réaliser de mon point
de vue dans l'équation pour réussir ses
désirs le plus important c'est de savoir
que tout est un choix en particulier
dans un pays comme la france comme le
nôtre tout est un choix on peut choisir
d'avancé c'est mon choix
on peut choisir d'attendre et de se
plaindre
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya une
très grosse différence entre ce sur quoi
on peut agir
on peut agir sur soi travailler sur soi
s'entourer des meilleurs s'entourer de
bienveillance on peut agir sur le
matériel donner le meilleur de soi dans
son job
on peut agir sur s'investir dans une
maison et puis il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on ne peut pas du tout agir
on ne peut pas agir sur le choix des
autres on peut pas agir sur le choix de
quelqu'un s'il vous aime ou pas si vous
choisi ou pas on peut pas à jouir sur
les événements historiques sur les
avalanches les tsunamis alors à un
moment dans cette équation du désir il
faut lâcher prise
lâcher prise sur l'ordre sur le temps le
plus important c'est de rester focus sur
son essentiel sur sur son désir depuis
des années mais des années j'entends que
je suis ambitieuse enfin un peu comme un
reproche trop ambitieuse en fait
alors c'est vrai j'aime voir les choses
en grand
j'aime vibrer j'aime avoir l'impression
de contribuer mais en fait non
maintenant je sais je suis pas du tout
ambitieuse en fait je suis ambitieuse
mais de vie je célèbre cette vie je suis
plein de gratitude pour ce qui m'arrive
d'agréables de désagréable parce que
pour moi le plus important c'est de
mettre en oeuvre et d'avancé 20 mai
désir alors tout un prix un des prix
c'est le prix de la déception et de la
solitude quand on va verser dès hier
parce qu'il ya des personnes qui vont
pas comprendre qu'ils vont pas suivre et
le deuxième prix alors ça me lâche le
paye assez cher et je le paye beaucoup
c'est le prix d'être toujours en quête
n'être jamais arrivé et donc d'être vu
et surtout d'être jugé
comme une femme indépendante une femme
d'intériorité et surtout une femme de
pouvoir
en fait le seul pouvoir dont je parle
c'est le pouvoir de réaliser ses désirs
mais ça plaît pas toujours ça fait peur
peur de quoi
du changement peur du fait que oui on
peut réaliser ses désirs mais ça vaut la
peine parce qu'à la fin c'est un absolu
bonheur ce soir j'aimerais dédier cette
équation du désir à mon fils est l'homme
qu'il soit libre qu'il embrasse son
humanité qu il sorte d'énorme si elles
ne correspondent pas qu'il ait le
courage d'aller vers ces désirs profonds
qu'ils avancent vers lui qu'il s'aligne
qu'ils soient ambitieux de vis nous
serons tous là pour lui et pour les
générations futures
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]